[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
oh
and welcome back to the break room
where uh we give you updates on
everything nerd news from our very own
break room which is
a little sketchy a little weird
people want to come in here they want to
eat salads they want to eat snacks we
won't allow it and we want to yell over
them we want to definitely be involved
too much in what they're eating funny
thing is we keep inviting people to take
their breaks during this and they refuse
many of them
yeah
just off camera begging to come in here
but we don't want to allow we asked
ashley if she wanted to be on with her
salad and she just walked out the door
and never came back
she's actually wandering around with a
salad
i want to uh do a few uh rumor
confirmations no uh a lot of people are
wondering what's on my shirt today no
one was it is uh it's french's mustard
uh oh look at that shirt cam
is it french's mustard or did i just go
through a paint universe
if you want to be the mustard on on
tommy's shirt you know we're open to
sponsors for the mustard okay that's
right i'm not a french is loyalist
oh my god either way with all this
mustard talk um colonel mustard uh clue
uh
going off you're going through your
consciousness first off remember when
john was like we got to introduce the
show
so what we're going to do what i want to
say first and foremost is that uh if
you've seen doctor strange and
multivitamins great if you haven't we
are going off today yeah we are we are
spoiling popping off we're popping off
as tommy would say colonel sanders dead
in the movie
michael jackson remains dead in all
universes but we will be spoiling and
talking about it and it won't and it's
not even going to be like oh spoilers
are coming we're going to just say it in
passing we're not even putting the
banner up in fact we're going to try and
trust no the ban is
oh god well either way he needs those
notes because coming up uh we're gonna
be talking about a lot of stuff uh
doctor who
doctor
who we're getting a new doctor our 14th
doctor
james gunn says goodbye farewell
good night i leave and heave either way
he says goodbye to the guardians of the
galaxy sorry to spoil that for you guys
uh moon knight riders are just as
surprised at some of the outcomes as the
fans are is that possible i can't wait
to get into it i can't wait to get into
it because what does that mean just
right improvised the last the director
said you know what cut that entire page
out let me throw in my oh i forgot they
edit these things
i refuse to let any of my work be edited
that's why oh that's why we're live baby
doctor
unlike dr moon knight uh we got some
sweet doctor strange updates that are
filled with spoilers again just want to
reiterate and we're going to give you
our illuminati
um i'm also brought here today with some
very beautiful men all of them uh all of
them are my suitors uh right next to me
we got brandon barrick yes hello hello
suitor number one for sooner number two
we got tommy bechtole oh my moon and
stars i'd do anything for you
i'd die for you and then i'd come back
to life oh no
die again every day oh god uh coming at
number three
is zach huddleston burbank bad boy
and you can take that to the bank
bank right san fernando boulevard here
we are staying where we are
[Music]
oh god okay so anyways if you guys have
any multiverse and madness questions
absolutely any please leave them in the
chat yes uh one of our producers dotson
will gather them for us and we will
answer them all at the end with our
likes
yeah we already have some good ones
we're going to be answering a lot of
questions today um and also to keep in
mind uh we're going to be answering some
uh the super chats are going to go into
the swear jar i know that i always mess
up this swear jar discussion so feel
free to jump in and yell at me that i'm
saying it wrong but the super chats are
now gonna go into the swear jar and if
we reach a hundred one of us can claim
to swear yeah wow only one not all of us
this time philip is pissed with our
silver tongues on the other side good
good use of piss yes we're not counting
piss that's
but anything north of that son of a
batch of cooking anything north of pg 13
we're counting as a curse so we're gonna
hold ourselves accountable no free
curses no free curses but the second the
swear jar fills up yeah then the first
one of us that's right who can jump on
it gets a free target's full and i'm
like ding dong dixon baby oh my gosh
let's get into these headlines okay
big part of uh the break room here is
that we're gonna bring you all the news
that's that's worth chatting about and
uh we've got some non-doctor strange
news but then we got a whole lot of
doctor strange news we're going to cover
first the non-doctor strange news we got
that avatar 2 trailer
dropping on the front end of uh
multiverse of madness if you all saw
that
we certainly did eric has a breakdown
coming out tomorrow
he's getting
knee-deep and na'vi that's right
he's linking with everybody take him out
throw him away no more you eric eric is
out there trying to chuck his braid
inside of in san francisco
he's loose with the brain
any fictional whales that you can throw
at him eric is gonna
dissect him uh okay and then on to other
head not headlines uh there's a new
doctor and mt is freaking out because
now i should have googled how to
pronounce this young man's name but um
in kutigatwa yeah does that sound about
right has been cast as the 14th doctor
he uh you might have seen him in the
middle of him in sex education yes that
was and he's really good in it so that
that's gonna be fun right yeah the every
time we get a new doctor it's always a
lot of really fun seeing uh season two
episode one and uh sex education with
the main character in the car just fast
forward to it okay um it's the most
disgusting thing i've ever seen
my entire life let's just say the
fountain at bellagio looks like a slow
trickle compared to oh
daddy okay um oh uh we're not swearing
no swears uh the illusions are
gratuitous uh we got word that uh ashoka
tana
the series has started shooting so close
yeah i butchered them
[Laughter]
just started shooting i wasn't even mad
at the last name it was the first name
where you said
i was like okay are you a cop yeah
are you a car he's wearing a wire are
you a prostitute
you also have to tell us if you're a pro
no they don't okay um if you guess uh so
that's fun so we're presumably just real
quick
ahsoka um we know we're about to get
obi-wan sometime after that we're
getting cassian andor okay sometime
after that we're getting mandalorian
season three presumably ahsoka is the
one after that i would hope so oh yes my
sources at wikileaks tell me that that
is the correct
and then is it symptom after that we get
knights of the high republic i think i
think after that we get a ghostbusters
star wars crossover oh my god i've been
waiting for that call um it's also a bad
batch too oh yeah
sure yeah just talking live action but
that that
high republic would be oh that'd be
special
right well you heard it here first uh on
to some sweet sweet marvel updates uh as
as jessica previously mentioned james
gunn shared a heartfelt goodbye to the
guardians of the galaxy on twitter not
that they're going anywhere we haven't
even gotten that movie yet but they
wrapped filming on presumably his final
guardians movie um we don't know for
sure but everybody's kind of behaving
like this might be the end of an era
his post said after over 100 days of
shooting and over 3 000 shots this is
the slave for the final shot of
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. presented
to me by the camera crew it was an easy
shot of rocket seated first with sean
gunn and then nothing there and took
everything in me not to break down
sobbing on the spot what a coward
oh my god
i do love it every time i'm reminded
that sean gunn does all the mocap yeah
i'm like oh how nice and again you know
if you're going to get to pick your
siblings yeah pick one who's going to
become a famous director
and and then have an agreeable sibling
that'll do
very very difficult motion capture yeah
yeah him as weasel was a little too much
apparently he seems like he's great at
it uh undo some moon night uh news um
that was written in the prompt no it
wasn't that was not a zac adlib
yeah if i was ad living it'd be on to
oink oink oink moon knife
okay did you guys know that beluga
whales can mimic human species
that can't be true it's true they lure
divers to the surface
what are they sirens what is this
diverse this is how they mimic it
[Music]
that's from the little mermaid yeah
because the lucas got voices of angels
yeah
okay i had my balls cut off when i was
little it was made by singing voice
incredible balls are fine
over here
they call me the castrati kid
jeremy slater head writer of moon knight
revealed they made different versions
teasing
gore the god butchers
in moonlight someone predicted that on
this table here yeah one of us was
guessing that there'd be a little
crossover maybe gorsh showing up to slay
the eniad was that you brandon i'll take
it
too bad they were i was like something
smart i would say uh
sometimes it would be rumors where the
gods would uh suddenly talk of gore the
god butcher or someone killing gods so
it's not like they were gonna do full-on
christian bale walking into the pyramid
it was to be more alluded to
they generally knew the beats of love
and thunder so that nothing would
contradict oh well that is some goddamn
[ __ ] great
stop
news
sorry my nephew who's watching james
plug yours buddy in rewind
okay
tommy he's the first one to notice we'd
fill it up that's where i've been
staring at that thing the whole show
that's why i don't make eye contact he
got it
um okay uh muhammad diab the director of
munite mentioned the scene where stephen
and mark confront their mom in the white
void whoa that scene apparently got cut
out before the final
draft of the series did we see a scene
of her like in one of the rooms yeah i
thought she was like
i thought that was a quick cut
from when they were in like maybe they
were picturing it in their kind of
vision and she found one of the women
that were in the she wasn't one of the
women in the bingo area i think there
was like
maybe i'm miss remembering it but there
was like a teaser
feature you know
trailer before one of the episodes where
i thought we saw her in one of the rooms
like banging on the glass door to get
out much like margaret stephen had been
but i think they cut that uh that
obviously wasn't in the show no yeah
uh sleuthing viewers maybe let us know
if that really happened or if or if
brandon is tripping when you start
calling the tip line if you call it
[Laughter]
where they step on the bird bones that
looked like concho
was not scripted whoa someone didn't
cleave birthday
it is so funny that they straight up
were just like
the writer was just like i don't know
why they might have found a dead bird
the day of or they put it in his
apartment
department intern was just sitting
around trying to get coffee for everyone
no one's there the director runs it like
i need bird bones right now or the
sickest prop pa of all time slaughtered
a bird oh yeah whoa
dressing it and then was like anybody
want these bird bombs but i i do think
cause like eric had mentioned like there
there is this potential theory that like
uh none of those memories are real
they've all been implanted by kanchu but
that may be kind of pokes because one of
his pieces of evidence were those bones
there but maybe it's just kind of like a
quick reference it's not meant to have
big plot implications and then slater
also mentioned
that um it wasn't in the script right uh
the bird bones he doesn't know if they
found that out on the day or if it was
added he didn't mean you know wasn't
sure what it meant again it was just
kind of a cool visual reference that
they threw in there not meant to be more
okay uh now some doctor strange news
which there's tons of uh it made the
film i'm sorry i'm not familiar can you
just break doctor strange to the
multiverse to madness oh right right
right okay yes yeah okay good good movie
yeah we saw it last week remember we
talked about it for several days in a
row
yes i remember that
you get this guy on mustard and
everything's happening
the film made
185 million dollars at north american
movie theaters over the weekend i think
it's over 400 million globally which you
know uh
those numbers right can seem fake they
can seem absurd and we're post-pandemic
the numbers are all off and like what do
you compare it to i mean how much this
is affected by amc and regal up charging
right yeah it has more money to go see
dr
does to see the bad guys i paid a
thousand dollars to see the batman okay
wait a minute you might have i think
yeah i think well no it was just a guy
who he said he was projecting it on his
chest
tommy what were you paying for i was
right up on san fernando near
he's running [ __ ] bob thank you he said
four grand i'll show you a batman on my
chest and you said i'm in for a second
cause you're getting a tip my friend
you're getting a tip of another grand um
uh it was reported that apparently
rachel mcadams was set to actually play
three variants we saw two yeah uh rachel
mcadams versions right but apparently
there was going to be a third one um she
of course played the the normal 616
christine yeah she saw the scientist
variant
who do you think might have been their
third variant no i i will say that
i loved
the growth of that character from the
first movie into the segment i i was a
little worried at first you know not
having paid too much i try to like kind
of only half watch the trailers because
i don't want to i wanted to be a little
bit surprised i thought it was going to
be her wedding and then that was going
to be it for her and i was like i just i
mean i'm glad that they have such a good
actress doing that part but man it was
awesome to have her be like someone with
a ton of agency and helping and moving
the plot along her scientist variant
right yeah yeah
i got to
zap some demons i think a third variant
might have been like in the evil
strangers
like a mr freeze style like frozen
oh yeah i'm trying to find a way to heal
him that would be awesome
everybody chill
i think i want her to play like a major
part um and have her be the doctor
strange and doctor strange be the
christine uh only because she in the
interview she was talking about how she
was so excited to do a lot of action
because she was like i never get to do
action movies um and when i do i'm not
the one doing the action moves so it was
nice playing a different christine
that's out of the hospital and doing
something different because she got to
get out of that zone of being just like
in the hospital all the time so i'm like
go go the extra mile make her the
superhero plowed down by a bus and mean
girls
that was not much of a stunt
right yeah
faction
hit
michael waldron who wrote uh multiverse
madness and also head writer on loki he
said in an interview when asked why kang
didn't show up in multiverse madness he
said the biggest
best bullets came from wanda in this
film right so if you introduce kang you
know you would have
risked the movie getting overstuffed
there's already so much completely true
right like more more bad characters more
villains right like it diffuses the
situation more is not better it also it
feels like you would have to be p
pitting them against each other and
being like well who's the best villain
wander or kang and i'm like don't put me
in that world like i'm gonna say wanda
right now because i love that wong and
oh it was so good for me i was eating
this [ __ ] up eating this crap up
wow
no what are we doing we gotta figure out
how to punish him yet john make up a
punishment on the spot yell it out to us
docker pay i was eating oh no i need
more money because if i don't get money
how am i gonna watch more of these all
right so i was eating good point i was
eating up what wang said when wong was
straight up just like she is either
going to rule the universe or like kill
everybody and i was like that person is
so strong don't put kang up there and
that's what the darkhold says too right
that the scarlet witch will either like
rule or destroy the universe like it's
all like kenneth from 30 rocks yeah
someday we'll all work for him or die at
his hand
the first time we see kang in the movies
he's gonna have to be re-explained yeah
absolutely no we can't assume that
everyone else he's been in one episode
of the disney series i was trying to
figure out if that was a good or bad
thing to introduce kang so in loki
season two or in loki season one because
i was like now we're always like when is
he gonna appear next cause it's king
right we're constantly like he's gotta
be in there but they did that with
thanos right yeah that's tricky it was
like
the thing yeah
you saw the trickles with yeah
but um elizabeth olsen did an interview
and she said she expects to return in
the mcu i love i'm so happy that there's
someone else besides chris hemsworth
that's like i will do as many of these
yeah because i mean this is a great game
feels like everybody else whether they
are doing it to be cagey or coy or
because they already know they're coming
back and they're misdirecting whenever
they finish a movie they're like
this is probably it i don't know i mean
because it could be over for us and
elizabeth olsen is like i signed an
extension after every movie yeah and
quite frankly i'll be pissed
and you know we don't know everybody has
like different opinions on work in
general different priorities in their
life sure it's like no shots at anybody
that's like ah two or three of these and
i'm good you know robert downey jr is
ready to move on nothing wrong with that
but i i agree it's awesome when people
are like i'll do these till i die yeah
i'm fine with that as long as you'll
have me back
in front of a blue screen go like this
and like red will shoot out and people's
heads will get burned off like yeah well
and especially this first generation of
marvel actors right which she's included
in she's kind of the only person that's
ever played scarlet witch right she owns
that character you know what i mean and
she can continue to own it as long as
she wants you know great um uh back to
michael waldron he said we always knew
we wanted to introduce clea as strange's
new love interest about of course that
first uh post-credit scene where we got
charlize theron as uh clia
um he said she has a fascinating
backstory she's a niece of dormammo
and they have a lot of great adventures
in the comics but we first had to close
the book on christmas
that's interesting dr darkhold close the
darkhold book well i mean kind of
fittingly right strange got his closure
on christine right they kind of watch
with with ironically a different
christine
right like but like having that
different christine allowed him to kind
of like let her go i don't like that
being the closest yeah no business being
at the wedding being like i love you
like get out of here buddy this is not
the day yeah come on this is not your
day doctor strange okay know your place
your behavior is strange like very and
it's off-putting it's very so maybe a
little weird to invite your ex to your
wedding i don't know i think
it was
i think it's fine as long as your ex
isn't a superhero because there's too
many people there that were like you do
have to invite your ex if if sleeping
beauty taught us anything yeah that's
you invite the most powerful magic
person to the big guy that's right or
else they show up piss that's right
you bring this up every episode
everything's flipping beauty taught us
anything today
my princess that's not sleeping beauty
but
who is that that's uh
we've already got we've got a
wonderful roster of great questions that
folks have submitted
all your multiverse of madness questions
submit those we're trying to uh
accumulate all the the winners and we're
going to answer a bunch of these at the
end of this episode but first we want to
shout out uh the folks that help us
bring this episode to you and that's a
big old delicious thanks to our friends
at hellofresh thank you to our friends
at hellofresh we actually just got this
delivery at the new rockstar's office
we're opening it up what's on the table
white cheddar cheeseburgers spicy maple
chicken i got the sweet chili pork bowl
each meal comes in a in a bag
like this
here what do you what's in there what's
in this spicy maple chicken let me open
this bad boy up yeah well well well
let's see what we got here for the spicy
maple chicken well boys and girls we got
green beans yeah we got yams your sweet
potatoes depending on where you're from
things fall apart we got beans greens
potatoes tomatoes
you name it
uh we got some chili flakes
okay well we don't gotta get all the way
through all the eggs we got more green
beans oh my god there's enough to feed a
small army in here or one tommy
and then uh and then your your your
chunk of media and your chicken come
separate uh and so we're going to um
we're going to eat this stuff and uh
report back thank you hello fresh thank
you very much sweet chili pork bowl yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum i can't wait
okay great i am so that was yummy you
say great to yourself our hello friend
yeah uh taking it back to use that from
zach um uh yeah we're gonna be actually
eating those hello fresh
meals over the course of the week and
reporting back maybe you'll see some
cool home footage from folks's kitchen
um
but get yourself some farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonable
recipe seasonal recipes delivered right
to your doorstep with hellofresh they
make home cooking easy fun and
affordable and that's why they're
america's number one meal kit um we're
going uh like i said report back over
the course of the week on how delicious
the hellofresh kit was did you know
hello fresh is 72 percent cheaper than
restaurant dining tommy and i were just
discussing a sixty one dollar beef chart
baby mother's day thank god it only
comes once a year because
i can't be the only one that comes once
a year from that amount you could get
like a a week worth of hellofresh uh for
the cost of one beef tartare that time
he treated somebody too uh and or you
know save that money spend it on imax
movie tickets buy your cool t-shirts
whatever you like um
hello fresh is also letting you
customize your favorite dishes you can
swap out proteins you can do different
side dishes brandon insists on pork in
every meal oh yeah i insist on pork you
gotta eat all these pigs they're too
smart
uh so if you want to join us in our uh
hello fresh adventures and uh dine along
with us go to hellofresh.com break room
16.
that number is important uh use code
break room 16 because you'll get up to
16 free meals and three free gifts and
no no uh no bs i am going to use that
code please i need to start cooking at
home that's a great deal and i just want
to mention baby if you're watching uh
you were worth every penny yeah
and all me and zach was saying
zach threw you under the bus
there was no there was no regret it was
just like wow sometimes dishes cost
only dismay when my bank account was
like are you sure buddy
hey just a little quick mobile alert
that you are negative and it's not just
your attitude about this tartar
all right we also want to shout out uh
our friends at uh the epic hero shop
we've got a a great multiverse of
madness latest obsession t-shirt
available there it is
shattered madness is the name of that
shirt um that's a limited edition
special run shirt from our friends at
the epic hero shop that uh is a design
we not only contributed to but that it
directly supports all the work we do
here at new rockstars uh so check that
shirt out grab one for yourself yeah
have a little fun speaking of fun it's
time for mandatory fun oh now
roll my graphic
roll my graphics oh i love it i thought
you would have forgotten over the
weekend about this no
everybody was furious friday that there
was no mandatory fun roll that graphic
again for all the people that were
furious read the graphic names
training
officer mandatory fun as everyone knows
this is the segment that has been
sweeping the nation going virus on all
platforms going virus this is where i
take my three best friends in the whole
wide world and i make them have a little
non-optional
joy with me and guess what it's not
weird it's fun and it's mandatory fun
and today we're talking about the
illuminati
okay
they got illumina got daddy in the movie
spoiler alert now put the frame up
there is illuminati got wanda they
wandered off the plane of existence
all right so we decided it was time to
cast the replacements i gave each one of
you
an assignment to select six new members
from across the
pulp pop culture
some pulp removed pop culture universe
and then even phil that mysterious empty
seventh chair uh which one of you would
like to go first
uh i can go first okay and just to be
clear we are filling out our own
illuminati aluminum i want to make sure
i got the instructions right but these
are from not marvel illuminati these are
from all other pop culture universe yeah
you know what i mean let's face it we're
gonna need a new illuminati if you've
seen the movie it didn't go well for
them it didn't go someone got turned
into string yeah uh
yeah uh and so i was assigned to make an
illuminati for the star wars universe
and now we're we're supposed to replace
people right yeah we're supposed to be
absolutely had to write mine down i did
them on slack but we're not allowed to
have confidence i wrote mine down too
don't worry about your phone uh we can't
have computers in the break room because
we might cry for help yeah uh here we go
okay my professor x i mean this is a
gimme from the star wars universe it's
yoda i mean you gotta have yoda on there
yeah my gosh you gotta have the old guy
the old guy leading the gang yeah uh for
my mister fantastic this is gonna be a
swerver rooney whoa i love his swear for
rooney general grievous he's back
he's back and in this universe he's on
the illuminati is this just because he
has long arms he's got long arms and
he's a tactician right he's very smart
he knows how to do battle plans even
though the clone wars do them real that
was me that was making real democracy's
finishing move right the swear for
rooney that's where we're running uh my
mordo you gotta go lando calrissian oh
yeah yeah
is that just race match no that is not
just that okay i think it fits in right
because what are you saying mordor's
like second fiddle mordo's second fiddle
with doctor strange right
lando he's second fiddle to han okay
no that's fair you can have hot on the
illuminati he would never do it but no
one joined oh yeah you know what i mean
uh for my black bolt i have
the ghost of qui-gon jin oh
oh i like this star wars illuminati's
got a force ghost on it it's my boy
qui-gon they did him dirty man but he
was out there he banged
uh he banged anakin's mom
is really qui-gon jin's son yeah don't
listen to what the emperor's like
morning show us what the emperor said
qui-gon showed up to tatooine a few
years ago met this woman and when he
showed up again she was like i don't
know you and he's like you know me you
know that's right you know uh my captain
marvel's r2d2 oh yeah you gotta have him
r2d2 knows everything about the universe
he's so smart he's there for everything
he can get out of any situation he's
very important jess can you do your r2d2
impression for us yeah
wow
good every time better than ages like
my captain carter is ray skywalker you
gotta have her in there okay she's like
a good captain
carter type like she's late to the game
she's very powerful super powerful very
strong super powerful very strong they
all say she's super powerful anyways she
came up to me yesterday tears in her
eyes yeah he said brandon lots of folks
are saying that super strong that right
skywalker is so strong got the skywalker
name good breeding uh they say the
emperor was a dad i don't think so
um
and then finally my empty chair
it's jar jar binks baby yeah he's got
the empty share cause he got too dark he
turned to the dark side whoa cut his
head off that's right
jar dark dark
that's my star wars illuminati i'm
having a real hamstring issue okay are
you gonna have to stand up okay i got a
little charlie now and i just loved it
so much how about this is you know it's
live because i would never humiliate
myself physically if i wasn't in some
severe pain right now i shouldn't be
lying
can we get some hydration for tommy
maybe some electrolyte
get yourself maybe
anyone here know cpr i might drop your
leg
okay i don't know that was weird it
happens a lot
maybe we need another fitness challenge
phillip
all
right jessica you want to go or i don't
know
what is that maybe you should go okay so
i'll go um
i got a little meta on on on mine i have
the illuminati
of hollywood film director yes which
some would say is real yeah that's
actually the the true uh
watching right now and he's like we're
gonna report on this tonight um yeah
depending on where you stand on the q
and on uh spectrum uh so my uh professor
x i mean
there's a couple of good potential ones
but i went spielberg right still
relevant to this day one of the all-time
greats yes uh
a dean of directors yes spielberg states
for my reed richards smartest man in the
world i went with uh christopher nolan
yes oh that's good you know you've got
to be pretty smart to be coming up with
films that elaborate okay uh for my um
for my captain marvel
i went guillermo del toro oh okay okay
that guy could do anything very powerful
right um i feel like uh we're still
recovering from tommy's charlie working
thank you
so much
we
[Laughter]
john can you bring me some tissue
um
where was i guillermo notorious captain
marvel oh black bolt
here this is the thinker i went with the
coen brothers because much like black
bolt they don't speak that often but
when they do it's powerful okay um for
my uh who's left mordo i went with and
now i'm the thing i accused bran enough
of the magical black guys i did go with
spike lee okay
i think that's just how the paper lined
up i don't know that there's any thought
behind it other than that yeah and then
oh oh we're out of here
captain carter uh who did i put captain
carter oh i went with catherine bigelow
oh okay
i need it now hollywood doesn't give me
a lot of female options for directors
that's their fault not mine
okay
their fault
not a lot of women directors uh but
catherine bigelow because she can do the
stuff just as well as the man can't
that's great at making action movies
point break look it up k19 the
widowmaker yeah look it up near dark a
great vampire movie catherine bigelow
hurt
yes and then you didn't start with hurt
locker i should have started with you
right right you're on zero darkness
point break's a great nineties action
man one of the finest movies of all time
and the remake even better
don't watch it she had nothing to do
with the remake and then my empty chair
uh just for a curveball i went with paul
thomas anderson yeah just because i'm a
film geek and i i love me some uh
phantom thread or the master because you
know it's because of him and quentin
tarantino that fiona apple doesn't do
cocaine anymore oh yeah well thank you
thank you pta yeah yeah they were so
insufferable in a movie theater one
night they talked at her for like nine
hours and she's like i don't think i can
do this drug anymore
one more dollar till i get to say
another sweater
ah all right so that's a great list zach
thank you very much uh we're gonna about
90 more minutes of mandatory fun and
then we'll get moving on the rest of the
show jessica you ready to go yeah i
stopped crying oh god he was making me
laugh so hard so i chose mine as um
the uh fox animated shows fox animated
shows and i put professor x as mr burns
because it goes out saying uh unlike you
two i put stewie griffin as mortal
okay because it's very maniacal yeah
thank you thank you thank you
um i put roger the alien as captain
marvel oh perfect because an alien sense
i put captain carter as linda belcher oh
that would be very fun and cute um black
bolt i put as boomhauer because you're
not supposed to you can't understand
what i'm saying yeah i was speaking a
lot of english
there is an available swear and i don't
want to hog all the swears oh so is mine
yeah
and i put
bender as mr [ __ ] fantasy
yeah
[Applause]
that's a good one yeah i didn't know the
other
and i didn't know we were supposed to do
the mdgc uh so i guess for my empty
sweet i'm sorry i didn't just listen
three times oh i thought we didn't have
slack um i'll give it to duncan from
duncanville okay
okay we'll cut you some slack for that
slack all right well i made a list
myself before ripping it up again you
read it i did uh serial mascot oh okay
of course the leader of the serial
mascots is the great tony the tiger as
professor
x that uh i have uh toucan sam
taking over for mr fantastic okay uh
just follow my nose he's kind of a
know-it-all
you know he's like i can do all this
people could see what you were yeah
uh and again i know i'm part of the
problem and i'm just race combining
again i had the tricks rob at his mordo
uh because they're both always deceitful
right they're always pretending there's
something they're not mordo my old
friend and brother welcome back backstab
to doctor strange
that drinks rabbit is confirmed white
right yeah for sure
he's literally yeah okay he's a white
bunny uh
he's a white christian bunny and he's a
great candidate for the next president
of the united states as far as i'm
concerned uh okay captain crunch would
be black vote because no one wants to
hear that guy speak
no i don't think that guy's be captain
marvel would be the cheerios bee i think
we all understand why flying around
mysterious origins why can he speak um
uh for captain carter i have the
weedabix mongoose who is the winneback's
mongoose
uh something i made up but i know
wienerbex is a british cereal so enjoy
that
that's right i've got a little knowledge
of the uk uh and of course in my empty
chair it's that stupid cookie crisp dog
that always got the guy in trouble
because the guy's about to steal the
cookie crisp until the dog was like
maybe they'll take the dog on your your
caper that's what i'm talking about
commercial dogs are always stirring
stuff up well if i've learned one thing
with commercials this is don't own a dog
don't own any pets pets are overrated
team no pets
all right guys we're gonna wrap up
mandatory fun here but i did leave one
little element of this competition out
because i wanted to
uh kind of put you guys on the spot
unfortunately wanda has just arrived at
your guys's illuminati temple and i'm
gonna need each one of you to describe
the graphic death scene of one of your
new illuminati
the winner will receive a prize i'll go
first just kind of said that okay
uh and mine's actually a twofer uh as
the uh
as the uh as tony the tiger is bravely
trying to talk wanda wanda you're
great and she's like tony i wish you
hadn't come to this and she's twisting
him up all of a sudden the cheerios bee
comes flying in and wanda does this and
spikes him into the ground
stinger first so his only choice
to remove himself from where he is stuck
is to rip his own stinger out taking his
own oh i like that she gives him the
choice
save your precious tony the tiger or
maybe i'll i'll let you live the
cheerios bee and an act of heroicism
severs his his stinger from his cute
little bee booty and then he flies
towards tony the tiger and as he's
flying towards a bolt of red magic
slices him in half like a thanksgiving
ham you know the classic meal for
thanksgiving the classic sliced in half
thanksgiving
just like mom uses just one slice okay
very cinematic thank you thank you who
can give me their next death
in mind for the star wars illuminati
wanda would turn r2 into a human oh like
transform into a human only would maybe
flesh yeah made flesh all of his parts
made flesh finally he's a human he can
he can feel he can touch he can love
except she doesn't change his blood his
blood is still oil and he's slowly just
like he's only alive momentarily before
the blood the oil curses only alive
enough to feel the pain
and then he screams
excellent all right jessica um i think
the only way it will be really horrible
is if i took my nicest character so i
think linda belcher is going to run at
her
full speed and she's going to get
stopped by wanda juan is going to take
her glasses off her face with her power
crush it and then shove it down linda
belcher's throat oh my gosh so the glass
gets swallowed down she starts spitting
up like blood and then immediately she's
like my kids bobby and wanda's gonna
just break her neck oh
lovely gorgeous
um and then for me it would be
christopher nolan lunges at wanda she
freezes in midair with her with her
magic and um
snaps his brain in half with plot logic
okay she makes him go backwards in time
while the rest of the scene goes
forwards wow also he's his own
grandfather yeah and and somehow um
incepts himself all at the same time
well guys this is a very exciting moment
you're nominees
for best illuminati death oh
there's an award you guys i want this
trophy so bad in r2d2 six feet under
linda belcher belches out her glasses
frames and black blood evidently is that
what you said she had black blood inside
i never said black blood okay
oh oil right okay and of course
christopher nolan
you played yourself
and the winner is
well wait are they voting are you voting
i'm voting
the cheerios be tommy victor oh
no no no i'm gonna say i'm gonna say
r2d2 spinning up
yeah we got to get into this q a right
yeah we do we need to get into this
question so a couple questions that we
already got okay well let's look do we
want to go yeah
okay okay so skylar aldrich asked uh he
said in super chat if you know how
secret wars plays out and you
sorry if you know how secret wars plays
out then you know that doctor doom plays
a huge role in that story yeah but don't
use doctor doom then who would you like
to see phillip's place as the god king i
want it to still be doctor doom but i
think a good setup is king the car yeah
i was going to say
so good of a setup right now but i still
need doom and i think kevin feige knows
that i think kevin feige's like everyone
keeps harassing me about doctor
yeah he's such a great villain such an
iconic villain why not find a place for
him and now that they brought in okay so
which we can talk about later so now
that they brought in the fantastic four
like we now saw mr fantastic get ripped
to shreds like a little piece of paper
and i i like the idea that he's dead and
so when we do see the fantastic four
it's just susan being like my husband's
dead and i have all my kids left behind
doom could still come like doom has
potential to now officially come in with
that or any other any other multiverse
that's right
any other fantastic four that escapes
the incursion in their universe when it
comes to ours because did they get an
incursion because of the doctor strange
being there well yeah maybe like so we
know like from the movie right 838
incurred with another one and wiped out
that entire civilization what if somehow
the that mr fantastic and his family and
the fantastic four got out they escaped
and they come back oh and that's why we
have and that's gonna be the fantastic
four yeah that could be the fantastic
form i like that idea uh carlton childs
asked a question that we were just
talking about brandon uh why didn't the
spider-man and villains in no way home
cause an incursion right can they uh can
they only be caused by uh strange and
kang i'm confused on this
um yeah we were kind of talking about it
like so the way they described
incursions in this film like in the
comic books a lot of times they just
kind of happen naturally like if you
imagine universes out there one day like
our milky way galaxy will collide with
another galaxy and galaxies are mostly
empty but things can hit you know blah
blah blah
the movie i kind of set it up that like
anyone dealing with the dark cold and
doing this dream walking they're using
dark magic which comes from the dark
dimension which is dorm mama's dimension
to like you know dreamwalk into someone
else i think using the dark hold and
using that dark energy the dark
dimension kind of exists in between
universes right so when you start
messing with that you're wearing down
that buffer zone between universes and i
think that's what causes the
encouragement yeah so something like
spider-man's villains jumping over like
that's not causing because they're not
using dark magic that was strange's
magic yeah that was just like that's why
i like america chavez can learn
uh at comradesh like she can learn
sorcery supreme yeah things without
disrupting that that universe yeah yeah
because that's a good point like america
chavez is going to different universes
right she's not causing incursions right
that's cause she's using her own magic
to do it she's not using like that dark
matter specifically that dreamwalking
thing is what was cited as that can
cause encouragement because i think you
know talking about like the spider-man
villains everyone's like why would
doctor strange do that crazy spell
that's so powerful but he says in that
movie right oh we've done this runes of
cough call spell all the time but i
think that's because he who remains was
in place
so they were doing this powerful spell
and if things were going wrong he was
pruning it but now that he's gone and
like as kevin feige said his death means
that like that spell can go wrong
so it was always a powerful spell they
just had no idea i do i do love it that
like the mcu is particularly the um the
sorcerers have been bowling with bumpers
yeah they had in the gutters this whole
time they thought they were just great
at throwing strikes but really he who
remains was throwing bumpers up in the
gutters right and now those bumpers are
gone and oh man now we're getting
tonight um really pushing the bowling
metaphors today i like it uh you got
more to spare don't you yeah yeah
that will strike them from the right i
will say they did they did run a poll in
chat tommy and they voted your
illuminati death it's the best yeah but
that's just because mine was very close
tommy's like everybody loves you
the stealth jake you're making a wish
the stealth jh asked will agatha seek
revenge on wanda's kiddos ooh oh that's
funny dark i mean i think reed richards
kids are revenge oh my god and i can't
wait because she their child their
daughter is so smart and powerful that
it's like she could come back and kill
like especially when she's like a
teenager like i'm gonna seek revenge i
mean what a great thing too because
though
you know that multi versus wanda was
being possessed by a different wanda she
was still the one who physically killed
those people right and they're in the
same multiverse you don't even have to
cross multiverses to track her down
right and
in the comics uh reed richard's son he
can work warp reality and create
universes as he sees fit like he's hyper
powerful so i don't know how powerful
they're gonna make him here but like he
could certainly do something like that i
don't think i if anything i think agatha
is the way we get one six one to back
i think she's gonna feel guilty for her
right when she realizes when she when
she breaks out of west view she's gonna
be like uh it's my fault like yeah i was
trying to get the power away from wanda
because she didn't know how to handle it
100 in the end i wound up giving her the
dark hold and she ran off and did all
this i think she's going to feel bad and
try and get her back and this could be
the intro to the agatha that we know
that is like caring of one yeah because
in the comic book she's like a mentor or
i would say they keep going down the
road of agatha not being a good
character maybe she brings wanda back to
try to enslave her user or whatever
right and and this movie has showed us
like the dark hold it it possesses
people it it drives them to be bad
agatha had the dark hall that whole time
on division so maybe now she's been away
from it
and now she's like oh i really screwed
this up i should have been helping wanda
the whole time because she had the dark
hole when she was when she killed her
entire coven right because she had the
black fingers in that box
that's something i'll always debate
about what i mean well they said that
like you've been uh you've been
practicing magic
the darkest forms of magic and
[Music]
i don't know that that coven had the
dark holes oh like
i think she gets it later john and i
fight about this all the time oh i think
this show will show us when she gets the
dark cold yeah but like i don't think
she had it when she stole everyone's
shoes i think that was an innate power
but also it's never been stated
explicitly that the dark hole is the
only source of dark magic right
caissillius was doing dark magic without
the dark hole i saw a few dark spells
just like my sister's softball game this
guy's hamstring
he's definitely got some dark lights
got darn ligaments in my legs
that's fine you know what today's the
first day of the rest of my life okay
diet starts tuesday
we're cleaning the night and then we're
back oh yeah once tommy is done
andrew clara said do you think mardov
818 will still steal silt still revenge
and chase strange and clear through the
other dimensions because from his
perspective all his buds are dead and
it's kind of strange's fault i mean also
uh 616 mordo's still out there we didn't
see him in this movie but he's out here
he's still out there and then so is
christine and christine is studying the
multiverse so i'm like all right i i
would hope that christine's like my
doctor strange went mad off of this
stuff i don't want to give this to mordo
but it's like he can still technically
well and 838 christine might take over
the baxter foundation now with sue or
something like that right she was a
senior fellow you know i'm sure reed
richards was in charge of everything but
now he's gone and so sue in that
universe is probably like i i didn't
like the guy anyway he was kind of you
but i love the idea of 838 uh uh
christine being like okay that one
stranger's fine let's leave him alone
the other one's a problem this strange
is fine but we still need to figure out
uh strange anthony anthony vigil has a
great question how do you feel about
them calling the mcu earth616
uh we're gonna probably do a video about
this on the channel like that's a
thing right maybe maybe a lot of the
viewers know this right but like
traditionally there are numbers assigned
to all these different like in-canon
universes the comics universe currently
is earth 616. yeah main main mc main
marvel comics was always 616. they've
kind of toyed with that a little bit but
like it's usually what it is and then
like the ultimates had its own number
uh all they wanted to have and they've
actually kind of
ended the ultimates universe and
brought some of their favorite
characters
previously the mcu the film version of
marvel had had been referred to as earth
one nine nine nine nine nine right yeah
and that was kind of based on a joke
kevin feige said once where they were
like what's what's the mcu's designation
he was saying it was like i hope the mcu
goes for
19 999 years so we'll call it earth
19999. now i was looking there was an
interview done in 2021
with a producer on
what if i believe
and they asked him the same question and
he was like no the mcu is earth-616
uh and we kind of we heard new rockstars
we were kind of like well he's just a
producer maybe he doesn't know we have
to listen to like what kevin feige says
we never listen to our producers we
never listen to our producers
john uh so i think between like
that what we saw in loki where the film
strip said 616 of one of loki's memories
between
i don't know how
mysterio and the writer working for
mysterio knew that it was called six
well maybe he's thought in a dream i do
i don't like the idea because like if
you're in the mcu if you're a character
in the mcu
like comic books of marvel characters
don't exist well but the kind of do
there's a captain america comic books
yeah but there's not an amazing
spider-man there's not x-men there's not
uh new mutants or something like that
within the mcu so to them
they are the main universe they would be
616 right yeah
someone asked that kind of goes along
with this so it says john kranzinski six
one six read richard's confirmed so yeah
alison becker94 asked is john krazinski
six one six
definitely not
right that movie well that movie's not
even on the the but he's it doesn't
right well i mean they want to make it
but doesn't even have a director right
now so like they haven't gotten to the
point of casting i would assume right
but this is what john's all john he's
always wanted yeah he's always wondering
richards chris the crap talking about
this since graduating also do you think
the movie is going to take place before
he dies
or or it's it's the it's a different
version
i wanted to be that same guy
i wanted to be i wanted to be and i
wanted to be before he i mean i hope
they do a fantastic four movie and like
the end of the end credit is like sue
and the kids from 838 coming over and
being like we need our dad back pray
girl fragile says how do you think wong
will react to cleo
how does it how does that even work if
your body's literally like well when you
burn a body they do a lot of weird stuff
also did they show a burnt body in there
that just hurts when they pass over not
even like they showed up they showed a
lot of bodies and then there were a lot
of kids in my theater and i as the movie
was going on i was like you gotta get
this kid out there
babbling behind us last thursday who
sounded like they might have been five
now this movie is pg-13 and there's a
bit of a controversy online it trended
on twitter they're like whoa is this
movie too too heavy too dark to be pc-13
what's wrong with people it's it's not
real it's not really also said bring a
13 year old to or like
yeah
when i was seven i watched evil dead
okay okay that made me
the man you are today and i am today was
this a good example you put multiple
lights on i don't think it's a good
example the monsters away is on several
prescription medications to control his
mood and brain and
and doesn't like to walk alone at night
just by being six foot one and well over
300 pounds because guess what who guess
who doesn't care about your size demons
this is the argument for watching this
movie you guys show your kids some
movies and they'll be just like me i've
been watching horror movies since i was
like in third grade and i will say when
she crawls out of that mirror like the
grudge when she comes crawling out and
twists i was like yeah this is what
nightmares are made of like i watched
like freaking 13 ghosts and was like i'm
never going to be the same yeah
i think you know what i you know what i
look forward to in 15 20 years the
number of people that will be our age
then right who will be like what's the
first movie you saw that messed you up
and they're like for a lot of people
it's gonna be multiverse madness all
right
but back to like clea i really yes i
marked out when we saw charlize appear
as clay because i've been waiting for
her to get in the mcu she's like the
last
major like action female star that they
haven't cast yet once they had like
angelina jolie and like someone hike i
was like when are they gonna get good
old charlie sterling in there and there
she is that's clea what a great
character we know uh charlize can work
man yeah yeah she can do something
she's very active like we saw in the old
guard and then uh fury road and a lot of
stuff right like if if they let her if
if we get to see her do some stuff
sometime soon like she'll go all out
reindeer games too i don't think wong is
going to be happy though
especially when he sees his third eye
he's in back oh great but i kind of like
this idea that wong stays sorcerer's
supreme stays on he deals with that and
now strange can go have some some wild
adventures i see a good one here
pandemic jones don't love the name but i
appreciate the question do you guys
think scarlet witch is the best villain
we have gotten in an mcu movie this was
the first mcu movie where i really
thought anyone could die this is my
favorite villain
in general well it's also it's rare that
we get a villain that we've known for a
while before that's what makes her the
best villain is her storyline is so long
it's like it's like how we feel about
loki how loki was so emotionally driven
for us is because we've been with loki
for so long we've been with wanda for so
long we saw her life we saw the people
that died with her and then just to see
her and wanda vision get torn apart
again and then in this movie we're just
supposed to be like yeah what she's
doing is not justified um which is it i
don't think killing a lot of innocent
people is but it was just like i can see
the emotion behind her and i love a
justified villain and this is a
justified villain yeah i think this is
like
since thanos thanos was great and they
had tons of movie to kind of develop him
and he got two movies and we got to
learn about about his like you know what
motivates him what his drivers are i
think this is like a great step up from
that and they did it in one movie it was
only two hours yes like is incredible
yeah we have all this backstory to go on
but it was really cool i mean
there'll be some you know there'll be
some people that will make some
arguments for a killmonger a killmonger
here uh a thanos there even a zemo has
his acolytes out there right yeah but i
i would agree only because like fans you
know
she's been a hero and it's also this is
one of the first times we've seen
villains turn to heroes like bucky right
she did it in the first movie that she
was in right really yeah
i think jessica kind of just convinced
me i might i might go in there i love
her i love her longer too this is a
great point i hear red angel 525 says
will the darkhold still exist through
doctor strange's photographic mix
now that is a ques that is not even a
question i think that's a statement i
mean he still can i i so
is there a is there a dark hole
uh a wonder gore mountain in every
universe we would assume oh that's right
so the walls still exist
i was kind of blown away and they were
like oh she destroyed the dark hole in
every unit yeah that's kind of crazy
that's a big deal they only knew that
because one other dark hole disappeared
i mean you know and it was the one where
he was dreamwalking in that other
universe yeah but the rule of averages
if you see that one i mean you gotta
assume an infinite is it like occam's
darkhold yeah yeah
we'll take it at face value right but
does every temple get destroyed like
that's i won't take it at facebook and i
also i have one other question why
once wanda figured out that there were
multiverses
obviously her children that she
fabricated with her mind report why
wasn't she looking for pietro her
brother who died there's a difference
between being a mom and being a sister i
understand that but the k but i mean i
know she the her obsession with her
children that were not real was uh a
real tommy this is the problem
no i think i think i hear what you're
saying you drove her to this but cause
also tommy but you're right cause like
she could have been looking for a
universe where pietro and vision were
both still alive i think part of it is
one reason she was so attached to those
kids is because they her grief for
pietro and vision was like channeled
through these kids that's where they
came from yeah so really just in trying
to find the kids she's also trying to
find no that's that's fair i rescinded
my comment but i will say
uh one of my favorite comedians joel kim
booster had a great tweet that i saw
that it was
all of this could have been prevented if
even one of the other avengers just
maybe called wanda once or twice to
check in and see how she reach out to
you we're all just like yeah you're good
reach out i think the thing about it is
i just think they're too afraid of her
which rightfully so um i would be like i
can't fight her especially after hearing
about what she did to west view i'd be
like yeah i can't they also might not
have been able to find her yeah i guess
like dr strange might be the only one
who knew how to find it i would not yeah
this banner could find her the thing she
wants to do is talk to like falcon in
the wintertime all right
i mean yeah
could connect on having some shared jobs
who's there oh it's me ant-man
all right uh it's just paul ryan making
those like cutesy paw red faces like
yeah i think the only one she could
connect with is probably spider-man and
she doesn't remember who he is
we've got a lot of good um multiverse
questions here um someone said here's
five dollars from here's five we're
making exactly them from as far away as
five dollars uh ray jsp
right
ray jason he's one of my favorite actors
ray jsp uh said do you think the
character franklin will be explored now
that eight three eights reed admitted to
having children a possible revenge from
this op character yeah i think that's
like kind of what we mentioned that they
have a lot of options for how to
introduce the fantasy
though this world right of 838 that has
like
essentially become like this utopian
paradise in some ways if they see the
now and they've been messing with the
multiverse but they've been on top the
whole time that they've seen this they
might shut down the doorways it'd be
like we're not going anywhere also think
about i mean the next time we see 838 it
might be wrecked yeah there's a power
vacuum at the top all their mightiest
heroes just got watered it's mordo at
the top now
he's in a pit
i don't think that i don't know they
clearly don't really intervene but do
you think that we might get a watcher
soon that's like
everything's gone down i'm looking in
the camera right now and i see how
bloodshot my eyes are crying and
laughing and i hate it but uh if the
watcher shows up that'd be so great
because that's the biggest person i
could honestly intervene and probably
won't tight like tight like tommy did
almost as much damage with this panel as
wanda
um you know
you guys crack jokes and you're the
heroes
i get a little leg cramp and i'm a
monster doesn't seem fair
uh amv asked couldn't earth 838 use the
time stone to reverse the aluminized
death thanos never got it oh good point
eric pointed out in the breakdown that
when we saw dead thanos right he he did
not have all the stones in the gauntlet
but they uh they they talked away their
doctor strange who's gonna use this time
stone right who's going to do the spell
who's going to do the spelling i like
that the way black bolt took him out was
to say i'm sorry yeah it still doesn't
matter if you're an abuser and you say
i'm sorry
for somebody
our good friend chrissy i i assume this
is our egyptologist uh friend chrissy
asks i've never seen any star wars
movies or shows but i'm planning on
watching them all soon should i go and
release order or chronological order i
think we have videos on our channel
about this yeah yeah if you could i
would say go in chronological order uh
go release you got to go relax i would
love to do release but okay as okay okay
different different different people
here different people here between me
and brandon brown's very smart and i'm
very stupid i have such a hard time i
have the hardest time
keeping up with the order of what it is
chronologically every time we talk about
star wars i go brandon what where are we
i'm like where does this take place i
think eric has in that one of those
videos there's a cute way a cute way to
do it yeah you start with episode four
and then you jump back to the previous
get all that information and then get
back on track yeah that's a lot of fun
playing chronologically it's fun because
there's all these end jokes you don't
get yeah and also there's a lot of
series right are getting depending on
when you start when you finish chrissy
that might change right as soon as
you're getting inserted into the middle
of the ground that's not true
she's chronological he's release date
but somehow they make it worse uh we i
already answered this but we're gonna
say it anyways whiskey bravo 85 asked
could i get the house of hardness play a
role in bringing wanda the scarlet witch
back to the mcu hell yeah it could my
girl is going to bring wanda back baby
great
we're going to suffer for that how dare
you let her down said one will kang
appear in the mcu but he's definitely
coming back in well we know ant-man and
the water he's confirmed yeah yeah yeah
yeah swandomania but i think like secret
wars or secret invasion could have a
little king action in it uh jacqueline
jones that's a great name by the way
jack thanks for giving me ding dong
dixon can't wait to use that one hey
you're more than welcome guys ding dong
dixon is for everybody that's the most
profane word in the world we kind of
teased this a little bit mota awesome
asked how the heck did mysterio know his
dimension 616 could be playing a bigger
role in secret like doctor doom maybe
so really we should credit his writer
because he remember he had i forget the
guy's name uterman gooder man there was
like a whole team working on the
mysterio project yes and the writer
wrote in the like six one six items
i love the idea that he had a dream one
night and it was like his version and
well i mean we know dreams are you have
a different dimension right yeah which
is a crazy thing that that could be
called back to that movie and they could
be like yes you were establishing it all
along i also wonder that we do know that
there are scrolls on earth
uh at that time and ostensibly they
could know about multiverses so a skrull
could have whispered that knowledge into
either good that could be a
stronger
yeah steve guttenberg could be a scrub
confirmed
we know he's a cocoon we know uh we know
he's uh a green man and a little lady we
know he helps robots get back on top
right but we can't talk much about that
deep cuts for the zoomers watching she
said do you think they will play they
will pay off the ned as a sorcerer plot
point from nor no way
from no way home or do you think that
this one and done cheap mcguffin well i
feel like we got some good news here um
or not we got i i hadn't heard this
before that like in no way home that was
originally scheduled to be america's
chavez who was gonna be bringing in the
different spiderman they they ended up
moving around they gave ned that ability
instead which is interesting so it
wasn't necessarily part of the long-term
plot that ned get to use sorcery it's
kind of a
a change of convenience but that doesn't
mean they won't use it going forward
you have to use how we're gonna address
it and then also his entire like the
joke i guess or whatever that his family
or a long line of like magical people
and then he easily can just open a
portal i'm like do you think he forgot
about is that wiped from his memory all
that portal stuff well only only like
that peter parker is spider-man is
technically the only wife from anybody's
memory so everybody still remembers the
blip everybody remembers but he doesn't
remember the fights right yeah i think
because their masks are on and off so
much i wonder if like all of that stuff
from from mj and ned gets wiped out more
in a way i don't know well i mean but he
said his grandmother is the one who said
or said that he had magic right right
but
but all our grandmothers tell us we have
magic
beautiful grandmas uh but yeah he might
have forgotten that i mean we saw the
effects of doctor strange being like
yeah i don't know where his web comes
from because he yeah in his butt
i forgot that was a scene in the movie
where he was like i don't know he's like
generally i've never seen him um billy
the kid lawrence uh he had a good point
he says the darkhold was a cop he's
quoting wong so agents of shield is
canon to the main timeline got it thanks
wong i mean really trying to sneak that
one in there love that kevin feige might
send someone to your
but house of shield is definitely
a different
timeline maybe a branch timeline or
possibly a whole other universe they
have their own dark cold and agents of
shield it looks very different it's got
it was in runaways too it's kind of
sparkly
really quick i just thought about this
has nothing to do with shield um
uh
what so does
so doctor strange remember spider-man
yes and no spider-man he doesn't know
who spider-man is he knows there is a
spider-man in there oh because that the
the spell was yeah no one knows that
peter parker but he knows there was a
spider-man yeah okay i'm an idiot got it
i feel like that changed everything that
i thought about before i did not know i
thought it was like all spider-man was
gone okay cool just clarifying good uh
chris germano asked are we sure
multiverse of madness was our mcu and
not a variant wasn't it confirmed that
the mcu is earth 1999 what if multiverse
madness strange isn't ours i mean i
don't think they're willing to do a
whole movie and then later come back and
be like that was a different universe
sorry i mean this has got to be our
universe we're we've been going on the
earth one nine nine nine nine nine thing
because one nine nine five said it we
kind of adopted it uh but this seems to
kind of put we might have just killed
off a universe in one nine nine nine
nine nine
do we
wanna go around really quick
because we're talking about spoilers as
it is and we're getting closer to the
end of this do available
[Music]
no stop when that part showed up i
immediately was like oh my god is this
how we're gonna see mephisto i
immediately was like holy [ __ ] is my
fistful gonna show up is this how it
happens and then they didn't but i was i
was the entire time i was like so i
thought i i legitimately thought for
three quarters of that movie
that they were going to kind of
uh half measure and justify wanda's
behavior by saying she was being
controlled by a demon like either
nightmare or mephisto or something like
that where i was like someone's
whispering into her ear and like and in
some ways that was true because like the
dark hole
had corrupted her yeah right
but i thought that i'm glad they didn't
because i think that would have kind of
been like oh well she wasn't capable of
being it's better if it's her i agree
i kind of agree i was going to say that
same thing for tommy the entire
zombie strange sequence i really enjoyed
but since time you already said it i'm
going to go my second favorite i mean
it's so
wild and silly that musical note yes it
was just like
yeah that's something you never would
have predicted being in a movie like
this it's genuinely surprising and wild
and weird when you watch it like that's
certainly like a scene i'm gonna
remember yes absolutely i do think
that's a good point because there are
like some of the middle marvel movies
that were coming out when we were
getting like one a year i have a hard
time recalling specific scenes from
unless i go back and watch them and i
feel like this movie i could
specifically tell you scene by scene
what happened it was like a lot of it
was locked in so good i didn't get tired
at one point like that was the one thing
that i took away this is why i said it
was my favorite movie so far for the mcu
because i was like i didn't get tired at
one second there wasn't one second where
i was like oh it's a long discussion i
was into it the entire time with that
being said
zombie doctor strain
i was i was
i was so i was like every time we went
to a different universe i was like okay
how are we gonna get the marvel zombies
how are we gonna get the marvel zombies
and then when he was like they don't
have to be dead or they don't have to be
alive i was like oh my god i was like it
is just him coming back and i was like
coming back beautiful so i love that and
then obviously like everybody else when
mr fantastic showed up because i did not
expect at all for some reason for him to
be a part of the illuminati i'm an idiot
i did not think about it my i have a
two-part answer this question the best
scene in the movie pizza pop always gets
paid yes
because i know how special it was for oh
are you gonna get a challenge
i'm gonna get the tattoo if disneyland
doesn't start selling pizza balls
revoke my magic key status this moment
uh but really hear that you hear that
you hear that what's his name michael
chavitz who's that what was bob
champignon bob chapin michael chad
i did really i really enjoyed the
sequence of like wanda attacking
commerce yeah oh that was cool from the
cloud coming in slowly to her i love
that it's a huge cloud and she is very
he's right here
and you're like that isn't scary but
then like the whole sequence through the
mirror magic arrows where she goes run
every time i thought she was finally
like met her match i was like oh thank
god and i was like how is she just
walking through glass if you're a meme
maker in chat if you haven't already
done the like run bam bam bam bam bam
bam bam got it done and someone edited
that someone edited that also i i i got
very confused
there was a a green bull man there right
here
a heifer but well i don't think that was
a real couch they used to call me i
actually
shot do not you do not talk about my
friend jessica like that ever
ever
listen to me
that thing
that green ball came out of nowhere with
no introduction yeah and i felt very
scared
i needed someone to explain i needed him
i needed him to be like your name is
and i'm a magic bull like
come on man where'd he come from
it came from the planet heifer okay oh
okay uh that's the
thank you all so much uh for joining us
we're this is not the last time we're
gone
we're probably going to be stringing
this out all week okay so if we didn't
get to your question if you've still got
some hot takes some theories some
questions about multiverse of madness
come back tomorrow 3 p.m pacific 6 p.m
eastern ask it then we'll probably be
able to get to it then um and if you saw
the movie over the weekend why not shoot
us uh show us a tweet with the if you
took a picture a selfie if you wore a
costume send us those we like it as long
as it was in spiderman use the hashtag
and our break room
maybe maybe
if anyone sends me their feet they will
be auto blocked i don't care if you're a
friend if you're someone i interact with
positively on social media if you send
me the feet you will be deleted uh we've
got a great week on the break room uh
all week it's gonna be a blast uh and
we're building up to this friday we're
doing a very special friday the 13th
episode okay we've got a lot of stuff
planned
coming off of the scariest mcu movie
that we're gonna have on friday this
year i'm gonna dress up like a murderer
oh guess what that's gonna look like
right now
i'm gonna dress up
so thank you so much for joining us uh
hit that hello fresh link in the
description if you're looking to get
yourself some hellofresh otherwise have
a lovely day from all of us at the break
room to you
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you